Aunque la brecha se ha ido cerrando
sigue siendo muy amplia a pocos días de
que se venza el plazo para evitar un
posible default a través de un acuerdo
para Elevar el tope de endeudamiento el
gobierno de Estados Unidos y los
republicanos en el congreso siguen
divididos del lado de los republicanos
se plantea una disminución del déficit
por 4,8 billones de dólares para los
próximos 10 años mientras que la Casa
Blanca propone disminuirlo en 2,8
billones de dólares en enero el gobierno
biden alcanzó el máximo endeudamiento de
31,4 billones de dólares autorizado para
este año fiscal y en abril la cámara de
representantes de mayoría republicana
aprobó un proyecto para Elevar el tope
en 1,5 billones de dólares pero
condicionado a un drástico ajuste de
gastos que vendría de eliminar las
subvenciones Fiscales a la energía
limpia aprobadas en la ley de reducción
de inflación y revocar la condonación de
deudas estudiantiles el gobierno biden
que lo argumenta que los estadounidenses
ricos y las empresas deberían pagar más
impuestos
Este es un escenario con el que los
políticos estadounidenses no deberían
jugar porque la posición económica de
Estados Unidos y el dólar como moneda de
reserva mundial otorga grandes
beneficios al gobierno están jugando con
fuego sino actúan de manera responsable
y elevan la deuda
las negociaciones continúan y a pesar de
sus diferencias las partes confían en
que pueden encontrar un punto medio en
sus demandas antes del primero de junio
cuando entraría en peligro la situación
fiscal de la principal Economía del
mundo